bruce coleman of soul belly barbecue uh
you guys don't just do barbecue these
days you got some specials going on
right well you know the the growing of
the great things about barbecue is it's
kind of a
blank slate right i mean
yeah you can cook traditional barbecue
you know but that even that is crazy
right it's texas there's kansas city
sure it's carol it's all over the place
it's all different i take a chef's
approach to barbecue so you know we're
doing things like barbacoa tacos with uh
smoked brisket
making fresh handmade tortillas we
started doing taco tuesdays i like it so
it's fun
this is a smoked eggplant dish
which is it's very complex
but it comes off as very simple it says
lemon mint yogurt and duka which is an
egyptian spice mix with pistachio and
sesame cumin and coriander and some
chili
and it's it's
smoked and then we chill it and marinate
it so serve cold so and and people ask
for what on the menu
this is a smoked eggplant we actually
haven't started running it yet this is a
test yeah so we're going to start
running it because it works on the test
worked out well yeah that's just working
yeah so these are you know like i said
these are the barbacoa tacos just with
some pickled onions and cilantro and a
little bit of lime just really simple oh
yeah
you want to try that one i made that one
for you
absolutely and then last but not least
tonight is fried chicken night
we started doing some delicious fried
chicken
um had you ever done that before i've
cooked a lot of fried chicken okay so
yeah no it's not your first time this is
a skillet fried chicken too so it's
classic
done in a skillet peanut oil
with it has might have some butter and
bacon rendered into the peanut oil maybe
maybe not um and so tonight it's fried
chicken night it's 16 bucks you get a
half chicken coleslaw and bread and
butter pickles and then you can do some
mike's hot honey drizzled over it as
well
we also have a killer concert tonight
with rya light sound and jesse daniel
and this band okay now that's opening up
so it's kind of like working out great
because we've got honky tonk we've got
fried chicken you know it's gonna be a
fun night tonight tell people where to
find soul belly uh silva is on main
street and imperial so 1327 south main
okay you can't miss us we've got two
giant smokers and a big lit up pig right
in front of the restaurant uh yeah but
you can and it's really good so tuesday
nights tacos friday or thursday night is
fried fried chicken and then i'm working
on because my past life is italian a lot
of pasta yeah so i'm working on a sunday
pasta all right you guys are branching
out having some fun you know what i mean
all right then you have specialty drinks
on top of that oh yeah so
this is a specialty drink that i
actually came up with is my first
cocktail i ever came up with it's called
where the sun don't shine i hope i don't
spill this because i am not a bartender
am i doing this right i got to put my
elbows out right and it's a dangerous
one too because moonshine yeah so
there's moonshine in here okay um it's
based off a cocktail i had in victoria
bc and i've kind of flipped it on its
head a little bit but it's a coffee
based cocktail and it has bourbon cream
cold brew coffee which we also made a
cold brew coffee ice cube for it
and
moonshine
and popular corn that's a serious drink
you gotta try it it's very light
we're gonna go to break yeah
right because you know you never know
right all right thank you so much uh
soul man barbecue right yep and uh
tonight is fried chicken night and great
music fried chicken great music all
right we'll be right